Salut !
Je note tout.
Je note tout ce que je fais,
je note tout ce que je pense,
je note des conneries qui n'ont pas
de sens,
surtout depuis qu'il y a des téléphones où on
peut noter comme ça l'intérieur,
je note tout.
Et pourquoi je vous dis ça?
Parce que du coup,
quand je relis ce que j'ai noté,
je me dis : "Hey, ça, ça m'a vraiment servi en fait.
Si je l'avais su 10 ans en arrière,
j'aurais gagné un temps incroyable.
Donc, je me suis dit : "pourquoi pas tenter
une vidéo, 6 choses que j'aurais
voulu savoir il y a 10 ans."
Qui m'aurait, du coup, vraiment servi.
Et qui peuvent vous servir.
Et si ça vous plait,
j'en referai d'autres comme ça,
tant que j'ai de la matière en tout cas,
et si ça vous plait pas,
j'arrêtai.
Pas les vidéos...
Juste ça...
Allez, j'ai un cadeau aussi
pour vous dans cette vidéo.
C'est la version audio de mon livre,
"l'Antiguide de la manipulation",
que vous allez pouvoir
écouter gratuitement.
Voilà.
Alors déjà, c'est un peu ouf
qu'on ait sorti la version audio.
Juste un mois après la version papier,
ça n'existe pas en temps normal, mais on
l'a fait et il est déjà disponible.
Et j'ai vraiment un plan grâce à Audible
qui a produit le format pour que vous
l'écoutiez gratuitement.
Je vous en reparle plus
loin dans la vidéo.
Loïc ! Générique.
La première chose que j'aurais aimé
qu'on me dise,
c'est qu'il faut toujours donner
son avis sincère et ne pas se conformer
à l'avis des autres
pour leur faire plaisir.
Ça vous paraît vraiment très bête,
dit comme ça,
mais je vais vous raconter
une anecdote qui donne à réfléchir.
C'est un mec qui va chez ses parents
pour lui présenter sa petite amie
et, comme lui n'a pas le permis, c'est
elle qui conduit durant tout le trajet.
Ils habitent un peu loin.
Ils mettent quelques heures
de route et boum, ils arrivent là-bas.
La famille est contente de voir son fils
et de rencontrer cette nouvelle
jeune femme qui a l'air très sympathique.
Mais comme ils ont roulé toute la journée en voiture,
il est déjà 18 heures
et du coup, la mère du gars dit :
Est-ce que vous voulez manger ici
ou est-ce
que vous voulez qu'on aille au resto...
Je ne sais pas?
Pourquoi.
Parce qu'elle veut être gentille, en fait.
Il y a son fils qui vient,
qui vient présenter quelqu'un.
Donc, elle veut être très gentille,
bienveillante, disponible.
Elle propose toutes les options possibles,
mais dans le fond, en fait,
elle n'a pas du tout envie de bouger
parce
que le resto est à une heure de route.
Donc, ça fait un peu loin ...
En plus de ça, elle aimerait bien
rester posée chez elle.
C'est la fin de semaine, on la comprend.
Mais elle propose ça, quand même.
Et du coup, son fils se dit : "Oh là là attend,
si ma mère veut aller au resto,
on va lui faire plaisir.
C'est pas grave.
Moi, j'ai pas envie d'y aller,
mais, si ça lui fait plaisir, on va lui
dire oui.
Il faut que ça se passe bien.
C'est la première fois que je leur
présente quelqu'un, donc je
dis oui".
Et le gars dit OK.
Et il propose du coup
sa petite amie aussi.
Il dit : "ça te dit qu'on aille au resto?"
Elle, elle n'a pas du tout envie d'y aller.
En plus, elle n'avait pas très faim, etc.
Et puis, c'est compliqué d'aller
au resto comme ça, là.
C'était quand même plus intime,
mais elle s'est dit : "Oh là là!
Si ma future belle mère propose d'aller
au resto et que mon gars veut y aller
aussi, je veux pas mettre
la mauvaise ambiance."
Donc, je dis oui, évidemment !
Et en plus, elle sait que c'est
elle qui va devoir conduire.
Mais elle dit oui.
Du coup, la mère du gars dit au père
du gars : "Il y a tout le monde
qui veut aller au resto,
ça te branche ou pas?"
Et lui, il a une semaine de malade,
il est épuisé et se dit " Ah là là,
aller au resto une heure de route là-bas,
deux heures, on va rentrer,
il va être minuit.
Laisse tomber en plus.
Du coup, je travaille
quand même demain, etc.
Mais, il se dit : attends,
si tout le monde veut y aller,
je ne vais pas être le mec qui va dire
non et qui va faire tomber le projet,
et qui va faire le gros relou.
Donc, il dit : "oui,
bien sûr, ça me fait très plaisir."
Et voilà comment une famille de quatre
personnes va manger au restaurant qui se
trouve à une heure de route, alors
que personne n'avait envie d'y aller.
Et tout le monde le fait pour faire
plaisir aux autres alors que personne
n'avait envie de le faire.
Et je trouve cette anecdote parfaite
pour se rappeler qu'il faut toujours
donner son avis sincère et ne pas chercher
à faire plaisir à l'autre
sans donner son avis.
En fait, on peut donner son avis
et quand même faire plaisir à l'autre.
Mais dans le doute,
on est sûr que tout le monde ne prend pas
la même décision, alors
que personne ne voulait la prendre.
Deuxième chose que j'aurais aimé qu'on me
dise il y a 10 ans, même plus longtemps en
avant,
c'est : dans la vie professionnelle,
ne choisissez pas de métier.
Choisissez un secteur d'activité.
Rien à voir.
En gros, si vous choisissez un emploi
ou un métier, vous allez foncer tête bêche
dedans, mais vous êtes pas
sûr que ça vous plaise.
Vous n'êtes pas sûr de vous épanouir
là-dedans; alors que si vous trouvez
un secteur qui vous épanouit au sens
large du terme,
vous allez forcément aimer ça.
Vous allez forcément vous améliorer dedans
et peut être même devenir un spécialiste
ou un génie dans votre domaine.
Vous savez, c'est la règle
des 10 000 heures.
Je vous avais fait une vidéo
là-dessus en 2018.
En gros, c'est la différence
entre la pratique posée
et la pratique intentionnelle.
Si vous faites 10 000 heures de pratique
intentionnelle,
vous serez un expert dans votre domaine.
Mais je vous mettrai la vidéo en lien
à la fin, si vous voulez
la re-regarder ou la regarder.
Troisième chose que j'aurais aimé qu'on me
dise il y a dix ans c'est :
"apprends tous les jours,
même quand tu crois que tu n'as
plus le temps d'apprendre."
Apprendre tous les jours,
c'est quelque chose que je
faisais déjà,
lire tous les jours, etc.
Et puis, en 2016,
quand j'ai fait une vidéo par jour,
ça a été une année de jachère,
de nouvelles connaissances.
C'est à dire que je me suis reposé sur tout ce
que je connaissais pour vous faire
une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Et je n'ai rien appris de nouveau,
sauf le fait, évidemment, de monter
des vidéos et d'écrire des vidéos, etc.
Je ne savais pas le faire.
Je l'ai appris cette année-là.
Mais de la connaissance brute,
je n'en ai pas touché une goutte,
je crois, durant toute cette année-là.
Et c'est vraiment une connerie parce
qu'on ne peut pas rattraper ce temps là.
Et puis, on perd aussi
une habitude mentale.
Bref, j'ai pas mal regretté ça et je me
suis dit après, on peut
apprendre vraiment différemment.
On peut apprendre tous les jours
en écoutant des podcasts
dans les transports, en écoutant quelqu'un
parler qui a une connaissance et en apprenant
de l'autre personne,
même en regardant des vidéos d'ailleurs.
En fait, il y avait d'autres schémas
d'apprentissage que je n'avais pas
identifiés qui étaient
en dehors de la lecture.
Mais l'important,
c'était de se dire garde une demi-heure,
une heure dans ta vie pour apprendre
encore de nouvelles choses
chaque jour, quotidiennement.
Comme ça, t'es sûr, quand même, d'avoir
passé peut-être 500 heures ou 600 heures
dans ton année à écouter et à engranger
de nouvelles connaissances.
Et ça, c'est intéressant.
Donc, je ne regrette pas
de l'avoir fait à cette époque.
J'ai failli arrêter,
en fait, ce schéma là,
et j'aurais aimé qu'on me dise il y a dix ans :
"apprends tous les jours et il
y a plein de formes possibles."
Donc, je vous le pose là.
Quatrième chose,
celle-ci elle va pas mal vous passionnez,
j'aurais aimé qu'on me
dise il y a dix ans :
"justifie toujours ce que tu fais."
Vous demandez peut-être pourquoi?
Là, ça a un rapport avec mon bouquin
l'Antiguide de la manipulation,
parce que justifier, c'est convaincre.
Mais attention, pas justifier en mode
de donner des arguments de ouf
pendant des heures et des heures.
Non ! Justifier
le plus simplement possible.
Ellen Langer,
en 1977, a fait une étude très importante
sur le sujet de la justification.
Mais de la justification honnête hein, pas
de mensonge, pas de tromperie, etc.
Elle place son protocole
dans une bibliothèque universitaire
où il n'y a qu'une seule photocopieuse.
Du coup, il y a toujours énormément
de gens qui font la queue à cette photocopieuse,
elle fait appel à un étudiant,
qui va être complice,
évidemment, pour tester
différentes phases de son protocole.
Ça se passe en trois étapes.
Première étape, son étudiant qui participe
au test va au bout de la file,
au dernier qui attend,
et il lui dit simplement la phrase
suivante : "Excusez moi, est-ce que je
peux passer pour faire des photocopies?"
Et le nombre d'étudiants qui lui disent
"oui, vous pouvez passer" est de 60 pour cent.
Alors ça, ça apprend deux choses.
Déjà, que les gens sont gentils,
apparemment ... Non,
ça apprend deux choses, ça apprend que déjà,
il n'est pas vain de demander.
En fait, plutôt que d'essayer
de gruger et de passer devant, etc.
Ou d'inventer un mytho.
60%, c'est quand même un gros chiffre.
Et la deuxième chose que ça apprend,
ça veut dire que les gens connaissent leur
degré d'urgence puisque le gars attend
aussi pour faire des photocopies.
Donc, s'il le laisse passer,
c'est que c'est OK.
Deuxième étape, donc plus tard dans la journée,
le même étudiant va, ce coup-ci, pas au bout
de la queue, mais, au tout début,
c'est-à-dire au moment où
la personne va faire des photocopies.
Il s'insère à ce moment-là,
et il dit : "Excusez-moi,
est-ce que je peux utiliser la
photocopieuse parce que je suis pressé?"
Eh bien, figurez vous
qu'on l'a laissé faire
dans 94% des cas, c'est énorme !
Mais la justification était biaisée
parce qu'en fait, il n'était pas pressé
puisque c'était pour le protocole.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe avec la
justification la plus honnête possible?
Alors là, c'est la dernière
phase du protocole.
L'étudiant va également au niveau
de la photocopieuse,
juste avant que la personne, qui vient
d'attendre durant tout le temps,
s'en serve et lui dit la phrase
suivante exacte : "excusez-moi,
est-ce que je peux utiliser
la photocopieuse car je
dois faire des photocopies?"
C'est incroyable, vraiment, c'est ...?
C'est la justification la plus
honnête et la plus basique possible.
Et bien 93% des étudiants
l'ont laissé faire.
Comme quoi, il n'est jamais vain de se
justifier honnêtement et sans chercher
à argumenter durant des heures.
C'est-à-dire à juste donner le sujet
à l'autre pour qu'il puisse
se mettre à notre place.
Fun fact!
J'ai utilisé cette technique aussi il y a
quelques années à la gare de La Rochelle.
Je devais prendre un billet.
J'étais un peu à la bourre et donc,
dans la file d'attente,
j'ai dit : "Est-ce que je peux aller
au guichet parce que je
dois parler au guichetier?
Et tout le monde m'a laissé passer
et j'ai pu aller parler au guichetier.
La sixième chose, ...
Je sais qu'on est à cinq, mais la sixième
chose pour vous dire, ce sera :
pourquoi, il ne faut pas se fier
aux gens qui réussissent.
La cinquième chose que j'aurais
aimé qu'on me dise.
Il y a 10, 15, 20 ans,
c'est :
"Apprend à croiser tes temps
intelligemment.
Croiser tes temps
intelligemment, c'est-à-dire pas
faire une pause sur ton téléphone
pendant que tu veux travailler, tu vois.
Ou pas travailler
pendant ta journée de repos.
C'est pas ça, croiser les temps.
C'est plus, utiliser un temps obligatoire,
un temps passif, pour faire quelque chose
d'actif ou de plaisant,
c'est à dire un temps de métro,
par exemple, ou un temps dans le train
ou un temps dans les bouchons.
Ça, c'est un temps passif, plus
ou moins obligatoire.
On peut en faire un truc de plaisant,
par exemple en jouant sur on aime jouer,
en appelant quelqu'un qu'on a envie
d'appeler et avec qui on n'a pas
le temps de parler habituellement, etc.
Ou un truc d'utile,
par exemple en écoutant un livre audio
qui va nous apprendre
des choses.. Ouh, il me voit venir.
Donc, oui, c'est le cadeau de cette vidéo,
l'Antiguide de la manipulation.
Il est sorti le mois dernier.
Il vient de sortir en livre audio,
alors que même-moi, je vous avais annoncé
qu'il faudrait six à sept mois,
comme n'importe quel livre audio.
On s'est démené avec LIZZIE et Audible
pour réussir à le faire et à le faire,
bien évidemment.
Et, pour celles et ceux qui vont se poser
la question, oui, c'est toujours
moi qui lit mes livres audio.
Ça, ça n'a pas changé.
On a réussi à faire ça grâce à Audible
parce que le livre est pour le moment
en exclusivité chez eux.
Donc, Audible, c'est une plateforme de livres audio
où il y a plus de 600.000 titres,
dont plus de 15.000 en français.
Et vous trouvez toutes sortes de livres
audio, des romans, des best sellers,
des livres de coaching,
du dév perso, de l'histoire, il y a de tout.
Et les livres, à chaque fois,
sont lus, soit par des comédiens professionnels,
soit par les auteurs comme moi.
C'est ce que je fais à chaque fois.
Il y a même des leçons de cuisine en audio.
Bref, vous avez compris
l'Antiguide de la manipulation est dessus,
ainsi que les anciens livres, d'ailleurs.
Mais surtout,
tout le catalogue de chez Audible est
accessible pour 9 euros 95 par mois...
En temps normal.
Parce que ça vous permet
de télécharger un livre
audio gratuitement par mois.
OK.
Sauf que là, je vous mets
un lien dans la description.
Vous le voyez d'ailleurs
apparaître ici.
Avec Audible,
on a mis en place un truc,
c'est que vous avez deux mois gratuits
en passant par mon lien,
ce qui va vous permettre d'écouter
mes livres audio gratuitement,
si vous le souhaitez.
Et c'est sans engagement.
Donc, après c'est vous qui voyez, si ça vous plaît,
que vous voulez continuer
à écouter les livres audio ou pas.
Ça vous permettra de m'écouter parler,
moi ou les autres, évidemment.
Quand vous êtes dans les transports,
quand vous faites du sport,
quand vous faites du ménage,
quand vous faites quelque chose de passif
ou d'obligatoire qui ne demande pas votre
attention, vous pouvez continuer
à apprendre en même temps et en écoutant.
Et, ça correspond aux conseils précédents.
C'est quand même assez pratique.
On passe au sixième.
Qui est sûrement mon préféré et peut-être
le plus important conseil que j'aurais
aimé recevoir il y a dix ans.
"Ne vous fiez pas
aux vainqueurs ou à ceux qui ont réussi dans
les domaines que vous aimez."
Alors, dit comme ça,
ça paraît bizarre, mais c'est vrai si je
souhaite devenir un chanteur très connu.
Rassurez-vous, ça n'arrivera jamais ...
Il ne faut pas que je me fie à tous
les chanteurs très connus et à leur
histoire.
De me dire : "Ah, c'est comme moi,
il vient de rien,
il habitait dans un petit village....
Nananin... Et c'est en faisant ça, ça, ça.
Après BAM, il a réussi.
Donc, si lui a réussi, pourquoi pas moi?
En réalité, il vaut mieux se référer
à ceux qui ne réussissent pas.
À tous ceux qui n'ont pas réussi
à atteindre son niveau,
parce qu'il y a forcément
des leçons à tirer de ces pièges.
Ça s'appelle le biais
du Survivant et c'est passionnant.
Le meilleur exemple que je puisse vous
donner, c'est les bombardiers
de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale avec Abraham Wald.
En gros, les bombardiers rentraient
à la base, mais il y avait beaucoup,
beaucoup, beaucoup de pertes.
Donc, les militaires se disaient : "il faut
absolument renforcer les bombardiers.
Il faut les blinder".. pour pas qu'ils ...
.. parce que ça coûte
très cher, quand même.
à produire, un bombardier ....
Donc, pour qu'il rentre à la base
et qu'on arrête d'avoir des pertes.
Donc, ils se sont mis à étudier tous
les trous ou les impacts de balles
sur les bombardiers pour renforcer les
zones qui recevaient le plus de balles.
Et c'est là où le statisticien
Abraham Wald a fait :
"Non ! C'est pas ça qui marche."
En fait, on va renforcer toutes
les parties qui n'ont pas reçu de balles
et tout le monde s'est dit :
"Mais pourquoi, Abraham?"
Ce n'est pas logique, il
n'y avait pas eu de balles, là.
Parce que Abraham ne s'est pas fait
avoir par ce biais là, du Survivant.
Il s'est dit là, on est en train d'étudier
les avions qui sont rentrés,
donc, ils n'ont pas eu de problème.
Donc, a priori, les balles qu'ils reçoivent
à ces endroits-là, ne posent
pas de problèmes à l'avion
pour revenir à la base.
Donc,
ceux qui ne sont pas revenus ont
potentiellement reçu des balles
aux autres endroits en fait.
A ceux qui n'ont pas été touchés
sur les bombardiers qui sont rentrés.
Et c'est comme ça qu'ils se sont mis
à renforcer les endroits qui n'étaient
pas,
qui ne recevaient pas de balles
sur la grande majorité des avions
qui arrivaient à revenir à la base.
Et c'est comme ça qu'ils ont
amélioré le renforcement.
C'est un vrai mode de pensée à 360 degrés,
de contre-exemple,
et c'est vraiment quelque chose,
dont je me sers,
depuis une dizaine d'années
pour penser ....
Attends, j'aimerais bien faire ça.
Comment ça s'est passé pour ceux
qui n'ont pas réussi à le faire?
Ça m'a ouvert des trucs,
ça m'a fait gagner un temps fou et ça
m'a débloqué des choses mentalement.
Et ça, j'aurais aimé le savoir il y a....
... là, la vidéo c'est 10 ans en avant, mais là,
20 ans avant, ça aurait été vraiment le top.
C'est pour ça que je vous le pose là.
Alors évidemment, je pourrais vous dire
d'autres points que j'aurais aimé.
Qu'on m'explique 10 ans avant,
15 ans avant 20 ans avant.
On peut faire une suite de vidéos là-dessus
ou même, dans les commentaires,
me dire vous aussi, ça serait trop fort,
le truc que vous auriez aimé qu'on
vous dise il y a 10, 15 ou 20 ans?
Alors si vous avez de 18 ans, plutôt il
y a 10 ans...
parce que il y a 20 ans, vous n'étiez pas né.
Je sais que Loïc vient faire apparaître
un poisson...
C'est presque sûr...
Quoi qu'il arrive,
j'espère que cette vidéo là, elle vous a plu.
Un peu plus à l'ancienne, d'ailleurs.
Moi, ça me demande de faire des vidéos
comme ça de temps en temps.
N'oubliez pas du coup que grâce à cette
opération avec Audible,
mon livre audio vient de sortir et que,
en plus, il est dispo gratuitement
avec les deux mois sans engagement.
Le lien dans la description.
Et puis, vous pouvez découvrir
tous leurs autres titres.
Merci à eux.
Quant à moi, je m'appelle
toujours Fabien Olicard.
Pensez à vous abonner,
si c'est pas fait. Ou si,
youTube vous a désabonné à Ma chaîne
principale et à la chaîne secondaire,
où il y a quand même du contenu.
Au minimum une fois tous les 15 jours.
Les vlogs du bureau, c'est assez cool.
Bref, vous avez les deux chaînes qui
doivent être à peu près par ici. Et là,
je vous mets deux autres vidéos.
Une, sur l'Antiguide de la manipulation,
justement,
où je vous parle de tout ce qu'il y a
à l'intérieur du livre avec les exemples
du triangle de Karpman.
Et ici, la vidéo de 2018 dont je vous
parlais dans la deuxième astuce
sur les dix mille heures
pour maîtriser un sujet avec
la méthode active d'apprentissage.
Prenez soin de vous ! À très bientôt.
Tchao !